since this is gq i usually don't pop but
i'm gonna pop a little today we set the
trend to say yo we're giving you free
work us us three right here that's why
the people love us
yeah yeah what's up y'all you know who
it is
right now we're about to take y'all
through some of our iconic tracks yeah
y'all ready let's go
[Music]
yeah but working with x is always you
know the energy is up a lot of good
vibes a lot of good flowers in the air
you know what i mean and he actually
bought us the rough riders and we got
the deal on bad boy first it was only
right to put him on the first big single
big record
[Music]
x was a superstar to ourselves yeah
already he was already a star he come
through with a luther tape with no
luther songs on it right his name on the
sharpie and sell them joints for 25 30
50 back then after the five songs go off
luke to come on
i think his hunger i think anybody who
ever seen him perform a rap at the time
knew he was bound to be a superstar
absolutely he possessed the energy that
was unmatched the dog thing is not just
a gimmick or a promo the man is dog god
bless his soul like you know what i mean
that's that's what he embodies what i
remember about money power respect you
know he was new on bad boy we was
knowing the game we was a little scared
to ask cam to get on the hook she was a
little busy at the time but it was able
to happen
[Music]
be honest in the studio that day it was
a surreal session like we we're from
yonkers new york we're on bad boy
basically the chicago bulls of rap we
got our brother x with us we're repping
yonkers we got kim in the next room
we're making the hook and playing with
the hook money power respect you know
that's a staple term in hip hop house
that's why we just did our first hour i
think even for new artists who don't
even know who we are they know the term
money power respect and that's from
that's what we were striving for
[Music]
we got a pack of beets from alchemists
or there's some controversy with that
beat too yeah he did
i actually paid for it i think he gave
it to me
first what i think happened was
miscommunication
i don't think the business was handled
on his side or cause i don't know how
you could sell a beat twice once we
heard it and once i loved it i did the
agreement right away to lock the beat in
i think grass was pissed off a little at
first but it should have been without it
shouldn't have been with me
i ain't i'm not a producer i just heard
it and reported say that they'd be wrong
[Music]
with our favorite albums
there you go i came from the block it
was in the studio i swear there was a
rough round of studio working on it i
was like what y'all doing i heard that i
said fire i think i left somebody got
right back into the hood
it was it probably went just like that
just like that i miss mariah mary patty
labelle i miss everybody
it's so crazy and didn't take it as
serious like getting on that record
until like later when it blows up you're
like man i want to you know i should
have been on that instead of hanging
outside chilling or doing whatever
so that's how that went
back and forth in and out what made
y'all do that how did y'all write it
what's the process like we started from
just admiring all of those before us
yeah epmd
mlp
run dmc it's an art it's part of the art
like you know
mcn is a craftsmanship especially pmd
the timing of the in and out and slick
rick and dog too [ __ ] nas and a-z it's
kind of a nerdy thing i guess you still
use two mics yeah
and to be able to start learning
space
and fill it in you write it together and
learn it then you gotta lay it with the
spaces in there yeah so can you imagine
doing the whole version you gotta do two
leave out four dude
and then the timing has to be very
precise so it's always been a dope
hip-hop thing to do it's showing our ass
man we got good [ __ ] timing man tell
me if you know someone that needs you
the one we own is 11 minutes long yeah
that's crazy
he's the hardest he's got an 11 minute
song a few of them he basically made a
triple album 11 minute song is
incredible yeah your whole treadmill
with one of them
ready
you're gonna lose 12 pounds playing this
house
the one thing you guys do say is he
ain't following nobody's [ __ ]
template absolutely not that's that's
why that's right
[ __ ] be different there's a lot of
[ __ ] i don't like but if it's [ __ ]
different and you follow yourself [ __ ]
it man get your money man like five
people with me and said that yeah he was
gonna call me then he finally text me
congratulated us from verses and said he
wanted to work with us was we willing to
come to atlanta that night i told him
yeah send a jet he actually sent it we
went we flew to the falcon stadium they
played us a few cuts off donder and they
played as jesus lord they said that's
the song they wanted us on we got some
accessories that we needed i got a few
pots of coffee brewed up and we knocked
it out left there seven in the morning
went to the hotel showered up ate some
lunch went back to the arena to the
listening party i'm strictly trying to
cop those colossal-sized picassos tell
them the messy part luke
she was already in the studio when we
walked in yeah he was working on
something else with it yeah and puff
said yo i got y'all got to hear
something he turned the beat on and she
was just like yo let me hear you all
right let me hear something she asked
all of us to rap and that's when she
heard the lyrics and then she when it
was done she was like yo and y'all gonna
write pup verse we ain't even know who
she was she just turned around started
dancing and doing the beatbox and stuff
like yo we thought he was making us keep
that track we didn't like that beat that
first like yo this is giles the first
ditty has for all about the benjamins we
was actually having a writing session
the locks in the midi room one day i was
rhyming that verse and he came in and
said i want that and i said you gotta
have it and he used it don't knock me
for trying to bury seven zeros over in
rio de janeiro the right version whose
decision was that that's perfect that's
all
about the benjamins
with the cuts i just wanted to give more
to the y'all working with biggie who
else comes in the game has the first
song with biggie and he's going at you
when you just came from yankees i think
big was the one who put the battery in
our back for real for real like once we
was able to meet him in the way he
embraced us and kept telling us that he
loved us and he was happy we was down
with him and when he heard us rhyme and
he was like
[ __ ] y'all rhyme rhyme you know
it's an honor gangsters don't die they
get chubby and move
miami but it gets deeper we was out
is deep to
touring doing spot dates but we got the
call that you know jay wanted us to come
to the studio to get on his album they
called as soon as we got from baggage
claim like we standing on the curb ready
to get in the car service and we like
yeah now we do the song let us go home
jot the luggage hey like nah we need you
to go
right now
we made this collective decision that
you know we gonna go straight there
think segal was dead see he was there
danger was there hover made beans round
for us until his mouth got dry then
he pulled up the beat and we laid
reservoir dogs right there that is my
verse for that night yeah i don't
remember yeah
they had to go to a club or something so
pete had to come back the next day and
actually lay his verse and i laid my
verse
and i come out hope's like oh i hear you
baby you was having us
drinks huh ain't the only one who knows
that what was that like
you really got to ask him what he was
doing but i mean it was obvious to a
duck i used to think stout was doing
that yeah like making that
was very
involved because he called me for the
original call him for the reason he
loves that kind of call him for the rest
you know call me for the remixer hey you
know what i kind of think that was him
being smart doing what we did
make sure you while you going corporate
you're paying attention to what's going
down downstairs and cover your bases
what was your why would we like with on
state property i would say when that was
a very intense time yeah that was
different that was a different time and
we were younger men we were all immature
coming from the concrete jungle yeah we
was in the hip-hop industry with a lot
of dudes coming fresh off of street life
we had hung out with each other as rough
riders and rockefeller a lot in kind of
studio sessions we built some sort of
camaraderie so i guess when it started
it was
a little weird it was weird and
offensive more than your music side
you know your street style started
kicking and you started thinking other
[ __ ] i was on the internet because you
talking to him you talking to me it was
like that you swung on him you might as
well swung on me and that's true
[Music]
the golden era is some i think the time
of maybe probably the illest lyricist
that ever lived right or wrong yeah go
back through the dates go through the
history go look who the [ __ ] did as much
mix tape work as we did we always been
to people's group to say hey all right
we do this other [ __ ] on the side but
we're the guys you'll actually see
outside we the actual guys who put out
mixtapes per week even when we was on
bad boy when everything was doing great
he was doing great
underground yeah he was making our bones
over there so they they knew us from
that we basically created the mixtape
lane no artist really lived off it until
they seen what we did and how we did it
then you've seen
50 murdery two chains murdered little
wayne murderer it became a thing to do
because we figured out we can't get on
the radio or get no singles out you
gotta find a way to be alive so we was
used to putting out consistent work and
feeding our fans for free like we
literally made up hey all right we get
paid off of this we do this but we love
this [ __ ] we respect who came before us
we'll lay some ill [ __ ] throw that [ __ ]
out for free
if you hope we wouldn't make it [ __ ] you
talk with a heart full of hatred [ __ ]
you that whole album you know we was
just happy to be on rough riders we knew
swiss before he made one beat all for
the love is his first placement
and then roughriders anthem and all of
that we used to be running around
back and forth out of town and um
supposed to call me like yo convince my
uncle to buy me a keyboard man beat
machine machine and stuff like that yeah
we denied a trillion swiss beats before
we accepted we knew him when he was
still like figuring it out
can you talk about the uh electrolytes
we knew we couldn't beat puff
lawyer-wise or money-wise so we had to
play mental chess figure out what was
our assets and our assets were the
people before we did it we knew that it
was a chance that
this might be a bad thing but this is
the only way to do it and if we're going
to do it let's do it we started the
whole campaign at some at a big
continent in the years so it's crazy we
had the t-shirts we had the whole arena
saying that yeah
for 16 years we put out the trinity oh
no no but people seem to think like we
got back together and we we own a studio
together we see each other a few times a
week for all of them years just
everybody started doing solo things and
opening up businesses and doing and
ownership never got around to a big part
of it was really ownership and what we
could
what we could get out of it it didn't
make no sense for us to do something
that we had a problem with and not be
able to make you want to just reap the
benefits of it
work work for ourselves shout out to
puff you gotta gotta log
our relationship with diddy is solid we
good catalog back thank the lord
top five that all live and that's just
one lp
you went up to the radio to do an
interview with greenland
he acts as the freestyle and we did that
but that stayed in our head cause we
played uh pop one of football that would
be a song that we would sing going to
away games on the bus then green
produced it and made it real song and
happened to be a nice call and response
hook that the crowd always responds you
can throw it on to this day they can't
sing the rest everywhere we go oh people
want to know
[Music]
in the 90s we had a reputation one
because we was from yonkers everybody
was from all the boroughs we didn't do
security
but we didn't let nobody
d block us we ain't let nobody d blocker
so we
will come through and it'll be a problem
and we'll work it out ourselves and it
means discipline dedication and
determination
that's what the d stand for top off the
that log is like iconic did you know
that it was going to be a thing nah that
just rhymed with the
thing before that
you got some balls to say that yeah you
gotta it takes a little it takes a lot
of gumption as he was saying biggest
that's cool you know when people say it
nobody be like get the hell out of here
you know i know a few rappers they say
they top anything
you gonna hit a bunch of busted tires
it's always whoever lays it and then
less like he said unless sometimes it's
like that would sound better first like
if i'm on the hook i probably won't go
first i'll probably go down somewhere
else yeah yeah you don't even want the
last version
you want to get on as quick as you can
they only play in 37 seconds and we're
always openly competitive i'm never
getting in the studio as i expect them
to and want them to have the better
verse but when they do have the better
verse i'm i'm not mad i'm glad because
they're still we're one exercise that
ego and pride with the competition not
your brothers you want to keep that [ __ ]
in house discuss whatever y'all got to
discuss behind doors get mad yell scream
but that ain't for everybody to know and
from social media
right instagram yeah that's that
[ __ ] you already love that man yeah
i ain't been broke together yeah i ain't
really [ __ ] y'all was lying to each
other from the beginning one of y'all
was [ __ ] ass part of my french yeah it
helps that we was a group way before
social media that's weird to us instead
of calling each other having to meet and
then you see what i posted about you
call me back after you look on facebook
[Music]
what is it let me see the locks it takes
loyalty yeah loyalty the only rap group
i think besides daylight shoulder mlp
who didn't break up no qualms we showed
y'all what loyalty is we showed y'all
what brotherhood is we showed y'all what
a code is we showed y'all what growth is
we showed y'all that we care for the
hood then we showed y'all that we even
want to give back and keep the hood
healthy we got the key to our city we
deal with the mayor the police the
criminals the ambulance the firemen the
mothers the
schools the hospital my legacy is we
gave a damn and we gave back and we
always been a hundred and million
percent hip-hop and we
were some of the nicest that ever stand
up guys too we like full-time dads and
all that like yeah
i like 42 i like little baby i like like
a lot of the music but it's the
craftsmanship i think they're giving so
much money to some of these young dudes
that they're getting
far away from craftsmanship as possible
all we want to see is that continue to
be here as some young dudes reach out
after versus like y'all i want to change
my show kiss i want to rhyme the world
because i don't want to go over
touch me more than anything no
like you can't be the older dude who
don't want to see
younger brown
black kings and queens make more money
that's what you were supposed to be
supposed to go it's supposed to be like
your generation it's supposed to set the
path for the next generation to make
more money like kish said as long as
somebody we got kendricks we got coles
we got all of these young gentlemen to
keep the craftsmanship so it's in a good
space you know what it is your boys the
loss
thank you
thanks for having us thank you very much
i'm happy we did gq this is crazy